he made his name on being rich and
successful in business
these new revelations suggest donald
trump is neither
the new york times reports that a
business empire built on golf courses
property and hotels has hemorrhaged
millions
his tax returns show what huge sums he's
lost
and what little tax he's paid in 10 of
the 15 years before he took office
donald trump reportedly paid no federal
income tax
in the year he entered the white house
he paid just 750
and paid a similar sum a year later this
story is going to reduce his chances of
winning the remaining undecideds
or converting people who tentatively
decided to vote for joe
biden the democratic candidate and he
needs some of those people
he does not have enough just with his
base
to win this time the new york times
reports
that investigators are looking into a
tax refund donald trump was given of
72.9 million dollars
after he claimed a large financial loss
he's personally responsible
for more than 300 million dollars worth
of loans which become due within the
next four years
and that as president he's earned
several million dollars in licensing
deals
in countries like turkey and the
philippines where his tax payments
have dwarfed the amounts he's paid at
home
the newspaper says he claimed tax
deductions on what most people would
consider personal expenses
including residencies aircraft and
seventy thousand dollars worth
of hair styling for television it's a
picture of business failure and tax
avoidance on a grand scale
albeit one the president insists he
doesn't recognize
totally fake news now actually i paid
tax
but and you'll see that as soon as my
tax returns
it's underwroted they've been underwater
for a long time
donald trump has been confronted on his
taxis publicly before
in a presidential debate against hillary
clinton for a couple of years when he
had to turn them over
to state authorities when he was trying
to get a casino license
and they showed he didn't pay any
federal income tax
so that makes me smarter being smart
is the debate line he may yet redeploy
tomorrow
but on tax avoidance now with a paper
trail
being smart enough just got tougher
james matthews sky news washington